Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic,
je vais tenter de répondre à un maximum des
questions scientifiques que vous m'avez posées.
Ne pouvant pas répondre à tout, j'enai sélectionné 10,
pour chacune destrois échelles de l'univers :
infinimentpetit, macroscopique et infiniment grand.
Commençons par 10 devos questions dans l'infiniment petit.
Jusqu'où peut-on aller dans l'infiniment petit ?
Quand on zoome de plus en plus,
ilarrive une échelle qui n'est
pas bien décrite par nos théories actuelles.
A cette échelle, les notions de temps
et d'espace semblent ne plus avoir de sens
et on ne peut plus zoomer :
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'échelle de Planck.
A quoi sert l'accélérateur de particules ?
L'accélérateur de particules va utiliser
des champs électriques et magnétiques trèspuissants
pour accélérer des particules élémentaires
à des vitesses proches de celle de la lumière,
leur donnant une énergietrès importante
et en les faisant entrer en collision,
on peut ainsi générer et étudierde
nouvelles particules beaucoup plus rares
quin'apparaissent que lors de ce type d'événements.
Est-ce possible de conserver de l'antimatière?
Oui, on est aujourd'hui capable de confiner
des antiparticules, en utilisantdes champs magnétiques
pour éviter qu'elles ne se désintègrent
en touchantdes particules de matière ordinaire.
Qu'est ce que la symétrie CPT ?
C'est une symétriefondamentale dans l'Univers.
Les initiales C,P et T correspondent
à la Charge électrique, la Paritédans l'espace et le Temps.
Pour simplifier, cette symétrie nous dit
que si on inverse la charge électrique d'une particule,
sa parité dans l'espace et le sens
d'écoulement du temps ,
tout revient au point de départ et la particule
se comporteexactement comme si on n'avait rien inversé.
Qu'est-ce que la physique quantique et à quoisert-elle ?
La physique quantique est
un modèle mathématique extrêmement précis
qui permet dedécrire les objets de notre Univers
à l'échelle des atomes et des particules.
Elle est vérifiéeexpérimentalement,
avec une précision incroyable
et a permis de mettre au point tout un tas d'objetstechnologiques,
comme par exemple les ordinateurs.
Pourquoi ne traverse-t-on pas les objets ?
Lorsqu'une pomme tombe sur une table, elle ne va pas la traverser.
Ceci est dûà l'interaction électromagnétique entre
les atomes de la pomme et les atomes de la table.
En effet, lorsqu'ils se rapprochent,
les atomes vont interagir très fortement,
de sorte à se repousser, ce qui va s'opposer
à la gravité et stopper la chute de la pomme.
Comment un photon peut-il posséder de l'énergiesans masse ?
Dans la nature,
posséder une masse confère à un objet une certaine énergie
c'estce qui est notamment traduit par la célèbre formule E=mc²
où E est l'énergie que possède unobjet avec la masse m.
Mais posséder une masse
n'est pas le seul moyen de porter une énergie,
notamment, le mouvement
confère lui aussi unecertaine énergie.
La relativité restreinte etla physique quantique
nous disent que, même s'iln'a pas de masse,
un photon possède une certaineimpulsion,
du fait qu'il se déplace à la vitessede la lumière
et donc une certaine énergie.
Qu'est ce que la constante de Planck ?
La constante de Planck est une
quantité propre à laphysique quantique qui donne,
en quelque sorte, la taille des plus petites
grandeurs possiblesque peut porter une particule.
Par exemple,
les plus petits paquets d'énergie que porte un photon .
Elle définit l'échelle à laquelles'applique la mécanique quantique,
carc'est justement à cette échelle
qu'onne peut plus faire d'approximations
et qu'il faut considérer que la matière est quantifiée.
La gravité existe-t-elle dans l'infinimentpetit ?
C'est une question très intéressante
car on n'a pas vraiment de réponse.
Oui, leseffets de la gravité
doivent forcément avoir une origine microscopique,
mais la nature de cetteorigine microscopique est encore inconnue.
Les nouvelles théories qui sont élaborées
comme lathéorie des cordes ,
la théorie de la gravité quantique
à boucles ou encore la théoriedes ensembles causaux,
cherchent justement à donner une description microscopique
dece qu'est fondamentalement la gravité.
Et enfin, comment un neutron peut-il se transformeren proton ?
Un neutron est composé de deux quarks Down,
de charge électrique -1/3, et d'un quark Up,de charge + 2/3.
Mais, sous certaines conditions, un quark Down peut émettre
une particule un peu spéciale, qu'on appelle le boson W -.
Le boson W - a une charge électrique de -1,
ainsi, enperdant cette charge,
le quark Down va maintenant avoir une charge de +2/3 :
il s'est transformé enquark Up
et le neutron est maintenant un proton.
On enchaîne maintenant
sur des questionsplus macroscopiques, à notre échelle.
Pourquoi l'eau s'évapore à températureambiante ?
En dessous de 100 degrés Celsius,
un volume d'eau liquide ne va pas entrer enébullition.
Par contre, comme notre liquide,
l'air contient lui aussi des molécules d'eau,
c'est l'humidité de l'air.
Naturellement, la vitesse
de certaines molécules à la surfacedu liquide
va leur permettre de s'échapper pour rejoindre l'air.
Certaines molécules
contenues dans l'air vont à l'inverse, venir s'intégrer au liquide.
Lorsquel'humidité de l'air est de 100%, il y a équilibre
entre le nombre de molécules
quiarrivent dans le liquide et celles qui s'en échappent.
Mais en général, l'air est beaucoupplus sec,
il y a donc davantage de molécules qui s'échappent du liquide
que de moléculesqui y retournent, et ainsi le liquide s'évapore.
Quelle est l'origine des mirages sur la route ?
Quand il fait chaud l'air à proximité
de la route est chauffé par l'asphalte
et ainsi, l'air enbas est plus chaud que l'air en haut.
D'après le phénomène de réfraction,
la lumière se déplaçantplus vite dans l'air chaud
que dans l'air froid, les rayons lumineux en provenance du ciel
vont être déviés, jusqu'à atteindre nos yeux.
Que sont les forces de marée ?
Lorsque deuxcorps s'attirent,
comme la Terre et la Lune,
étant donné que la gravité est d'autant plus
forte qu'on est proche de l'objet attirant,
un côté de l'objet, le côté le plus proche,
va être davantage attiré que l'autre côté.
En particulier, sur Terre, les océans et les
mers sont d'un côté très attirés par la Lune,
ils se soulèvent, et c'est la marée haute
etde l'autre côté ils sont moins
attirés que la planète toute entière,
ils vont donc resteren retrait,
ils se soulèvent dans l'autre sens.
Comment obtient-on un plasma
en variant lapression et la température d'un gaz ?
Dans des conditions ordinaires de pression et de température,
on ne peut tout simplement pas.
Pourobtenir un plasma, il est nécessaire d'ioniser le gaz,
c'est-à-dire de libérer certains deses électrons.
Pour ce faire,
on peut lui injecterun courant électrique très puissant,
le bombarder avec des rayonnements très énergétiques,
ou encorele placer à une température extrêmement élevée.
Pourquoi les ondes radio traversent les murs?
Chaque matériau est fait d'atomes,
et les atomes sont capables
d'absorber des ondes d'une certaine longueur.
Les atomes du mur et de tous
les objets que l'on peut voir avec de la lumière,
sont justement capables d'absorber les ondes
dont la longueur d'onde correspond à la lumière visible.
Mais les ondes radio ont une énergie
beaucoup plus faible que celle de la lumière
etleur longueur d'onde est donc
trop grande pourêtre absorbée par le mur.
En quelque sorte, lesatomes
du mur sont sensibles à certaines longueursd'onde
et si la longueur est trop grande ou troppetite,
alors, les ondes ne seront pas absorbées.
Pourquoi le son est plus rapide dans l'eau ?
Dansl'eau, les atomes sont
plus fortement liés entre eux que dans l'air.
En effet, l'eau est plus dense
et les atomes sont plus proches.
On peut se le représenter
en imaginant que les atomes dans l'eau
sont reliés par des élastiques très tendus
alors que les atomes dans l'air
sont reliés par desélastiques plus mous.
Quand on perturbe un atome dans l'air,
la perturbation va se propager plus
lentement que si on perturbe un atome dans l'eau.
Si on aspire une bouteille dans l'espace, s'écrasera-t-elle ?
C'est une bonne question.
Dans le vide, il n'y a pas de matière pour
exercer une quelconque pression extérieure sur la bouteille.
Imaginons que la bouteillesoit remplie d'air.
Cet air exerce une pression à l'intérieur, qui la fait gonfler,
et quand onouvre la bouteille, celle-ci va naturellementse vider
mais elle n'a aucune raison des'écraser,
car il n'y a pas de pressionextérieure sur ses parois.
D'ailleurs,dans le vide,
on ne peut pas aspirer unrécipient
car le fait d'aspirer, correspond justement au fait de créer
une baisse depression par rapport à l'extérieur.
Mais dansle vide il n'y a déjà plus aucune pression.
Deux objets s'éloignant chacun à 90 % de lavitesse de la lumière
ne la dépasseraient-ilspas l'un par rapport à l'autre ?
Imaginonsdeux vaisseaux
qui s'éloignent chacun à 90% de la vitesse de la lumière.
Observonsmaintenant la situation
depuis le pointde vue de l'un des deux vaisseaux.
D'après larelativité restreinte,
selon ce point de vue, c'est le vaisseau qui est immobile
et l'Universtout entier
qui se déplace à 90 % de la vitesse de la lumière.
Le vaisseau va donc voir
l'univers contracté dans cette direction
et voir le mouvement de l'autre vaisseau,
qui fait partie de l'Univers, également contracté.
En relativité restreinte, lesvitesses ne s'additionnent pas.
Au lieu d'observer l'autre vaisseau
se déplacer à180 % de la vitesse de la lumière,
le fait que l'Univers soit contracté,
implique qu'on voitseulement l'autre vaisseau se déplacer à 99,4%.
D'où vient le bang supersonique ?
Lorsqu'un objetémet des ondes sonores,
ses ondes se propagent à la vitesse du son autour de lui.
Mais si l'objetse déplace plus vite que la vitesse du son,
les ondes qu'il émet vont
s'écraser derrière lemouvement de l'objet,
formant une sorte d'onde
résiduelle qui prend la forme d'un cône.
Aupassage de cette onde, on entend un "Bang!"
Et enfin, pourquoi ressent-on l'accélération
mais pas la vitesse dans un véhicule ?
Dans l'univers, un objet va avoir naturellement
tendance à se déplacer en ligne droite et à vitesse constante.
Ainsi, dès lors qu'ilest lancé à la même vitesse,
le passager, son corps et tous ses organes internes,
vontse déplacer en ligne droite
et ainsi épouser le mouvement du véhicule,
tant que celui-cine tourne pas ou ne change pas de vitesse.
Pour finir quelques questions sur
l'infiniment grand et l'univers tout entier.
Qu'est ce qu'une exoplanète?
Uneexoplanète est simplement le nom qu'on donne à une planète
qui tourne autour
d'une autre étoile que notre propre Soleil.
La matière peut-elle êtreconstituée
d'autre choseque des atomes?
La matière est tout cequi possède une masse.
Généralement, elle est faite d'atomes mais pas toujours.
Unplasma par exemple, n'est pas formé d'atomes,
il consiste en une soupe d'électrons et de noyaux.
Lorsque certaines étoiles massives meurent,
elles laissent derrière elles un objet tellementdense
que sa matière n'est plus formée de plasma
mais seulement de neutrons, comprimésentre eux :
c'est une étoile à neutrons.
Comment les rayons lumineux peuvent-ils
êtrecapturés par un trou noir s'ils ne changent pasde vitesse ?
En relativité générale, la gravité
a la capacité à ralentir l'écoulement du temps.
A proximité du trou noir
le temps s'écoule moinsvite qu'à distance.
Pour un observateur qui se trouverait à proximité,
la lumière à côté de lui
se déplace toujours à la vitesse de la lumière.
Mais pour nous, qui observons ce rayon
lumineux depuis une position lointaine,
cette zone de l'espace semble évoluer auralenti
et donc le rayon lumineux se déplace plus lentement.
Cette différence de vitesse
apparente de la lumière entre différentes zones
va la dévier et l'attirer vers le trou noir,
un peu comme les mirages qu'on a vus précédemment.
Pourquoi la Terre ne grossit pas en relativitégénérale?
En relativité générale, on entend souvent dire
que ce n'est pas la pomme qui tombe vers lebas
mais le sol qui accélère vers le haut.
On peut alors naturellement penser que la Terre devrait grossir
si le sol accélère vers le haut de tousles côtés.
Pourtant, non, la Terre ne grossit pas.
Il est nécessaire de bien comprendre la notion d'accélération.
En Science, on appelle accélération,
le fait de dévier une trajectoire par rapport àson mouvement naturel.
En relativité générale,le mouvement
naturel des objets n'est pas laligne droite mais la chute libre.
La pomme quitombe,
est donc bel et bien en train de suivreson mouvement naturel,
elle n'est pas accélérée, c'est-à-dire
qu'aucune action extérieure ne vient perturber son mouvement.
Par contre, le sol,
s'ilsuivait son mouvement naturel, devrait lui aussi tomber.
Mais pourtant il reste immobile.
Celasignifie que quelque chose l'empêche de tomber,
le sol subi une accélération vers le haut.
Enl'occurrence, cette accélération
vers le haut est dûe à la pression répulsive
exercéepar les matériaux qui composent la Terre.
Comment l'univers peut-il s'expandres'il est infini ?
Imaginons une grille d'espace.
Cette grille est infinie :
oùqu'on aille, elle s'étend pour toujours.
Pourtant, on peut très bien expandre
chaque carreau de la grille, et ainsi,
en augmentant simplement
la largeur de chacundes carreaux,
on expand l'espace tout entier.
Pourquoi dit-on que l'univers n'a pas decentre ?
Reprenons notre grille infinie qui s'expand.
Du point de vue de quelqu'un sur Terre,
l'expansion de l'espace lui semble centrée sur lui.
Si on remonte le temps, on a l'impression
que le Big Bang s'est produit exactement ici,
Mais pour quelqu'un sur Mars,
le Big Bangsemble s'être produit ici aussi.
En fait, où que l'on regarde,
le Big Bang s'est produitabsolument partout dans l'espace
car il ne s'agit pas d'une expansion de quelque chose dans l'espace
mais d'une expansion de l'espace lui-même.
Que signifie un univers homogène ?
Un univershomogène est un univers qui
contient à peu près la même quantité de matière
et donc d'étoileset de galaxies ,
et qui est organisé de la mêmefaçon,
avec les mêmes lois physiques, où que l'on se trouve.
C'est le cas par exemple de notre Univers,
qui, pour l'instant, semble homogène à grande échelle.
Mathématiquement, on peut démontrer que
dans un tel univers,homogène et en l'absence de gravité,
les trajectoires naturelles des objets sont les
lignes droites parcourues à vitesse constante.
La théorie de la relativité est elle fiable à100% ?
Oui et non.
Oui, car toutes les expériences coïncident
avec les prédictions et ce avec une excellente précision.
Jamais aucuneexpérience
n'a remis en cause ses principes fondateurs.
Cela dit, il faut être conscient
que la relativité est un modèle mathématique,
peut-être qu'un jour une nouvelle expérience viendra la contredire.
D'ailleurs, il est important
de comprendre, qu'en tant que modèle mathématique,
elle est limitée à un certain cadre, en
l'occurrence les grandes échelles.
Si on s'intéresse à des systèmes petits,
microscopiques,on ne peut plus l'utiliser.
Ce n'est donc pas une théorie qui marche partout
et c'est pour cetteraison qu'on cherche aujourd'hui
à élaborer une nouvelle théorie qui pourrait
décrire à lafois l'infiniment grand et l'infiniment petit.
Pourquoi relativité et physique quantique
nepeuvent pas être réunies ?
Il est important de comprendre, qu'aujourd'hui
on sait unifier la physique quantique avec la relativité restreinte.
Ce qui pose problème,
c'est la relativité généraleet donc la gravité.
A l'échelle quantique, tout est quantifié.
En quelque sorte,
tout estformé de briques élémentaires.
Pour concilier les deux théories
on voudrait donc pouvoir quantifierla relativité générale
c'est-à-dire identifier les briques élémentaires
de la géométrie del'espace-temps lui-même.
Mais il se trouve que c'est
mathématiquement très difficile, voire impossible :
certaines quantités mathématiques
qui décrivent l'espace-temps deviennent incontrôlablement infinies.
Aujourd'hui,les chercheurs visent donc
à développer des théories complètement nouvelles
,qui, en partantd'une approche fondamentalement différente,
pourraient peut-être retomber, à la fois
surles prédictions de la physique quantique à petite échelle,
et sur les prédictions de la relativité générale à grande échelle.
On appelle ce genre
d'approche des théories de la gravité quantique.
Et pour finir, l'Univers est-il infini ?
A grande échelle, L'Univers possède une certaine courbure.
Cette courbure va déterminer si l'Univers estinfini ou plutôt fini.
En effet, supposons que l'Univers soit
courbé à la façon d'une sphère,
alors, tout comme la surface de la Terre,
l'Univers serait ainsi fini
et en marchant très loin dans une direction
on pourrait revenir ànotre point de départ.
A l'inverse, sil'Univers est plat à grande échelle,
c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas de courbure,
alors, dansce cas, il s'étendrait à l'infini,
à la façon de lagrille qu'on a vue précédemment.
Aujourd'hui onest capable de faire des mesures
très précisessur la courbure de l'Univers à grande échelle
et, pour l'instant, toutes les mesures
semblentindiquer que l'Univers est plat
ou tout dumoins qu'il est immensément
grand devant lataille de l'univers observable.
Ainsi on ne saittoujours pas si l'Univers est infini,
peut-être ne le saura-t-on jamais,
mais dans la mesure dece
qu'on peut détecter il semble plutôt infini.